تنظم علينا وتنورنا من رياض الفنانه هند
ياسين هند يسعد صباحك اهلا بك شكرا على
تواجدك معانا اف صباح العربيه ومبارك عليك
الفوز بهذه الجائزه القيمه من ورد كافضل
وجه مفضل تعال فئه المسلسلات تفضلي شعورك
بهذا الفوز كبير
يسعد صباحك اول شيء انا سعيده بالتواجد
معكم والله يبارك فيك يارب
شعوري بهذا الفوز كان ااا
رهيب كذا مختلف ااا
مختلط بين الخوف وبين الحماس بين الفرحه
بين بين كثير
الف مبروك
فماذا تريد هيلدا من المستقبل الدرامي
واعمالها الدراميه مستقبلك
ان شاء الله باذن الله هل ده شخص مره طموح
وكل
نقطه او كل انجازي سويه او كل شيء حققه
يشوفه انه هو نقطه البدايه
بنفس الوقت الحمد لله انه اليوم عندنا
اليوم الحمد لله عندنا دوله قاعده تدعم
المواهب بشكل يعني جدا كبير وزي ما شفنا
في السنوات الاخيره همم كيف انه في مواهب
شابه جدا مميزه وجميله ولله الحمد وهذا
كله من حرص القاده ومن حرص المسؤولين
ودعممهم ولله الحمد
وهذا الشيء يخليني انا فخوره
جدا ويخليني انجز اكثر
[موسيقى]
ويخليني يعني هذا حافز لي اني انا اقدم
الافضل دائما وشيء يعني يشرف مستقبلا
طيب الحديث عن الحافز يعني دالف هذا
التانيه تصريح لك بعد الحصول على الجائزه
قلتي انك تودينا الحصول على جائزه
الاوسكار يعني احيي فيكي يعني يعني هو هذا
الطموح والا اما اذا كانت هذه الجائزه
جائزه
بالفعل لك لتقدمي الافضل في المستقبل
شوفي هيلدا حلمت من عمر ست سنوات هذا
حلمها فالحمد لله يعني رسمت للحلم ااا
اكيد يعني
مريت ضغوطات ااا
مريت في مواقف حلوه وسيئه واشتهيت على
نفسي همم يعني تعبت كثير جاهزت ولله الحمد
يعني انا ما اقول اني نمت كل شيء بس الحمد
لله انا ماشي بهذا الطريقه
دائما الحمد لله
رب العالمين
بدها تغني ولا تمثل
شوفي هو التوجه الاساسي هو التمثيل بس اذا
كان عندي هذه الموهبه الثانيه ليش ما
استغلها مع التمثيل يعني داخله بالتمثيل
ما اكون كا ايوه يعني ما اكون كان مغنيه
لا يعني اكون اجمعها مع التمثيل لانه في
النهايه هو فن
اكيد فن والفنان بيكون موهوب فنان شامل
يعني تكون يعني ان شاء الله بالتوفيق دوما
واحنا بنشكرك على وجودك معنا من الرياض